It’s easy for any movie fan to remember
their favorite performances of all time.
Great acting efforts like Heath Ledger in
The Dark Knight, Jennifer Lawrence in Silver
Linings Playbook or Leo in The Wolf Of Wall
Street are always fresh in our minds.
Unfortunately, sometimes the most terrible
performances can be just as easy to remember
and can totally change the way that we look
at an otherwise well respected actor.
For this video we are taking a look at some
of the worst in our list of 10 Amazing Actors
With Bad Performances You Just Can't Forget.
Enjoy this video and be sure to hit the subscribe
button for more awesome Screen Rant content,
every single day!
Robert De Niro as Dick in Dirty Grandpa (2016)
For decades, Robert De Niro has been on of
the most revered actors working in Hollywood
with amazing performances in films like Raging
Bull, Goodfellas, Taxi Driver and so many
more.
In recent years, De Niro has made some odd
choices, opting for comedies and more light
hearted movies and for the most part his performances
have still be okay.
That was until 2016 brought the world the
movie Dirty Grandpa which showcased Robert
De Niro hitting rock bottom.
In the movie, the Academy Award winning actor
plays a widowed old man trying to have sex
with a college aged girl.
The movie is full of crude humor that really
misses the mark and it really was a shame
to see such a great actor stoop so low.
Colin Farrell as Bullseye in Daredevil (2003)
There are about a million bad things that
can be said about the 2003 movie adaptation
of Daredevil.
Ben Affleck and Jennifer Garner are famously
bad in their roles and we are sure people
are happy that Netflix has recently provided
Daredevil with an adaptation worth of it’s
hero.
With everything else bad going on in the 2003,
it can be easy to forget just how bad Colin
Farrell’s portrayal of the villain Bullseye
was.
Not only did he look super weird, Farrell
seemed to make all the wrong acting choices
and the character felt cheesy and fake.
It’s not like this was a terrible performance
in an otherwise great movie so we can understand
why people have forgiven him.
Russell Crowe as Javert in Les Miserables
(2012)
Les Miserables is arguably the most famous
Broadway musical of all and the 2012 film
adaptation got a lot of things right.
Hugh Jackman and Anne Hathaway were great
in leading roles and the live singing turned
out to be a great choice to preserve the authenticity
of the film.
The one aspect that really drags the movie
down is Russell Crowe’s luke warm performance
as the antagonist, Javert.
Not only is Crowe a very low energy character,
his poor singing stands out like a sore thumb.
When the movie came out, Crowe was seriously
ridiculed and it took a few years for him
to fight back from this poor performance.
Johnny Depp as Willy Wonka in Charlie and
the Charlie Factory (2005)
There was a time when Johnny Depp was pumping
out quality acting performances every year,
but those days seem to be long done.
Depp has given us amazing performances in
movies like Pirates Of The Caribbean and Edward
Scissorhands.
In recent years, Depp has turned in some pretty
dreadful performances but the one that sticks
out the most is his utterly creepy turn as
Willy Wonka in the 2005 adaptation of Charlie
and The Chocolate Factory.
Depp’s attempt at the beloved character
wasn’t just bad, it actually tainted the
memory of Gene Wilder, who famously played
the role in expert fashion.
Halle Berry as Catwoman in Catwoman (2004)
After Halle Berry took home the Academy Award
for Best Actress in 2002, it seemed like her
career was set to skyrocket to truly monumental
levels.
Then, along came an infamously horrendous
film called Catwoman.
This one wasn’t all Berry’s fault, but
her inauthentic and weird portrayal of the
titular character definitely didn’t help.
This movie/performance has been showing up
on lists of worst superhero movies for years
now and it will take a lot of bad movies to
knock it out of contention.
Other than an X-men film, Berry hasn’t done
much notable since but she will be appearing
in the Kingsman sequel in 2017.
Here’s hoping that she won’t be wearing
a weird leather outfit this time…
Nicolas Cage In 'The Wicker Man' (2006)
Let’s face it, Nicolas Cage's days of being
a respected actor are long behind him and
lately he is more commonly considered a joke
these days.
He’s turned in some laughably bad performances,
but none were quite as bad as his role in
2006’s 'The Wicker Man.
The movie was all wrong from top to bottom
but the most notably bad part was definitely
Cage’s infamously frantic Edward Malus.
His performance has been ridiculed for years
and has sparked countless online memes.
At this point, Cage needs to just embrace
himself as a joke or get out of the game completely.
Benedict Cumberbatch as Billy Bulger in Black
Mass (2015)
Benedict Cumberbatch is one of the best and
most respected actors working today.
From the small screen hit, Sherlock, to the
Marvel super movie Doctor Strange, Cumberbatch
has been pumping out great performances left,
right and center.
In 2015, however, Cumberbatch turned in a
pretty terrible performance in the Johnny
Depp led Boston mob movie, Black Mass.
Cumberbatch played Depp’s brother and his
character had a Boston accent, which he absolutely
butchered.
In his defense, it’s a tough dialect – especially
for a British actor, but he was definitely
the wrong guy for the part.
Luckily, Black Mass was a pretty big flop
so not too many people actually got to see
Cumberbatch out of form.
Hayden Christensen As Anakin in Star Wars
Prequels
It’s no secret that most fans were not very
fond of the Star Wars prequels and we are
sure that people are thankful that The Force
Awakens was generally well received.
One thing that most fans seemed to hate about
the prequel trilogy was Hayden Christensen’s
portrayal of Anakin Skywalker.
The writing wasn’t great, but Christensen
definitely did do much to help, as his performance
was both whiny and creepy.
After the movies, the actor received an unbelievable
amount of backlash, so we can understand why
he decided to stay out of the spotlight going
forward.
January Jones as Emma Frost in X-Men First
Class (2011)
Anyone who has watched Mad Men can confirm
that January Jones is indeed a talented actress
as she was fantastic in the role of Betty
Draper.
Unfortunately for Jones, the same definitely
cannot be said about her performance as Emma
Frost in X-Men: First Class.
Jones is very boring in the role and the movie
only really uses her for her sex appeal, putting
her in weird revealing costumes.
This performance was just a small misstep
for January Jones as her career has continued
well since.
The X-Men franchise has made some serious
missteps over the years, and this one was
just another on that long list.
Chloe Grace Moretz as Carrie White in Carrie
(2013)
Chloe Grace Moretz is one of the best examples
of a child actor successfully aging into a
mature adult actor without succumbing to the
traps of a young burnout.
Over the years she has proven that she can
do it all from horror, to action to comedy
and for the most part she has been very good
in her films.
Unfortunately, at the ripe old age of 19,
Chloe already has one performance that is
a real stinker.
In the 2013 film, Carrie, Moretz plays the
titular character and her portrayal is less
than memorable.
To be fair, the entire film is pretty bad
and we have to think that Chloe (and her co-star
Julianne Moore) probably regret deciding to
star in this flic.
So there you have it, there’s our list of
ten great actors who turned in some absolutely
dreadful performances.
Which one of these acting efforts do you think
was the worst?
What other bad performances totally grind
your gears?
Let us know what you think in the comments
section below and be sure to subscribe to
our channel for more fun videos – like this
one.